>>> AND WE'RE LIVE BACK IN FT.
MYERS, FLORIDA.
REPORTING ON THE AFTERMATH OF
HURRICANE IAN.
I WANT TO GO TO MY COLLEAGUE
NADIA ROMERO.
SHE'S WITH RON DeSANTIS RIGHT
NOW TALKING TO HIM ABOUT THE
RESPONSE HERE TO THE HURRICANE.
LET'S GO TO HER NOW.
>> LEE COUNTY, WHY DO YOU STAND
BEHIND LEE COUNTY'S DECISION TO
NOT HAVE THAT MANDATORY
EVACUATION UNTIL THE DAY BEFORE
THE STORM.
>> WELL DID YOU -- WHERE WAS
YOUR INDUSTRY STATION WHEN THE
STORM HIT?
WERE YOU GUYS IN LEE COUNTY.
NO, WITH YOU WERE IN TAMPA.
SO THEY WERE FOLLOWING THE
WEATHER TRACK AND THEY HAD TO
MAKE DECISIONS BASED ON THAT.
BUT 72 HOURS, THEY WEREN'T EVEN
IN THE CONE.
48 HOURS THEY WERE ON THE
PERIPHERY SO YOU HAVE TO MAKE
THE DECISIONS BEST YOU CAN.
LY SAY THEY DELIVERED THE
MESSAGE TO PEOPLE.
THEY HAD SHELTERS OPEN.
EVERYBODY HAD ADEQUATE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET TO A SHELTER
WITHIN THE COUNTY.
BUT A LOT OF RESIDENTS DID NOT
WANT TO DO THAT.
I THINK FOR VARIOUS REASONS.
SOME PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO LEAVE
THEY ARE HOME PERIOD, THEY'RE
ISLAND PEOPLE.
BUT SO MUCH ATTENTION WAS PAID
TO TAMPA, THEY THOUGHT THEY
WOULDN'T GET THE WORST OF IT BUT
THEY DID AND I THINK IT IS EASY
TO SECOND-GUESS.
BUT THEY WERE READY FOR THE
WHOLE TIME AND MADE THAT CALL
WHEN THERE WAS JUSTIFIABLE TO DO
SO.
>> SOME OF THE NABIN
G
THEY INFORMED PEOPLE AND MOST
PEOPLE DID NOT WANT TO DO IT.
THAT'S THE REALITY.
SO YOU'RE IN A SITUATION, ARE
YOU GOING TO GRAB SOMETHING OUT
OF THEIR HOME THAT DOESN'T WANT
TO.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S THE
APPROPRIATE USE OF GOVERNMENT.
I THINK THAT TAKES IT A LITTLE
TOO FAR.
>> WE HEARD FROM THE FEMA
ADMINISTRATOR TODAY WHO SAYS
THAT ANYONE, YOU'RE LIVING IN
WATER, THAT YOU SHOULD HAVE
FLOOD INSURANCE.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
>> YEAH, I MEAN, I THINK WHAT
HAPPENS WITH HOMEOWNERS, THEY'LL
SAY YOU'RE IN A FLOODPLAIN, YOU
HAVE TO GET FLOOD INSURANCE.
WHAT THEY'LL SAY IS, YOU'RE NOT
IN A FLOODPLAIN, SO PEOPLE SAY I
DON'T NEED IT.
USUALLY IT'S PRETTY AFFORDABLE.
THAT WILL BE SOMETHING THAT
PEOPLE WILL SEE.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE PEOPLE WHO
HAD TOTAL LOSSES WHO WOULD HAVE
BOUGHT INSURANCE IF THEY WERE
TOLD THEY WERE AT RISK, BUT NOW
YOU'RE IN A SITUATION WHERE
YOU'RE SEEING FLOODS LIKE NOBODY
HAS EVER SEEN BEFORE.
AND THAT'S JUST SOMETHING PEOPLE
WILL INTERNALIZE AND WANT TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT.
>> THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
CRITICISMS ABOUT THOSE
SKYROCKETING PREMIUMS DURING
YOUR TERM AS GOVERNOR.
WHAT MORE COULD YOU HAVE DONE TO
DO THAT MORE AFFORDABLE FOR
FLORIDIANS.
>> THAT'S A SEPARATE PROGRAM.
MOST OF THE CLAIMS ARE GOING TO
BE UNDER THE -- 15 YEARS AGO,
THEY DROVE ALL THE INSURERS OUT,
ALL THE BIG ONES OUT AND THEN
MORE RECENTLY WITH IRMA AND SOME
OF THE OTHER STORMS, YOU HAVE
MASSIVE LITIGATION AND A LOT OF
SCAMS.
SO WE'VE DIALED BACK SOME OF
THAT.
WE PROVIDED A FUND TO STABILIZE,
A LOT OF THEM WOULD HAVE GONE
OUT OF BUSINESS THIS SUMMER
ALREADY, BUT YOU NEED TO GET RID
OF THE SCAMS.
I'M CONFIDENT AFTER THE ELECTION
THEY WILL.
>> Reporter: WHAT IS THE TALK AT
THE STATE LEVEL OF TAKING
INTO -- ARE WE HAVING THOSE
TALKS AT THIS LEVEL RIGHT NOW?
>> WELL, I THINK IF YOU GUYS --
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE BASED IN
FLORIDA.
I CREATED A PROGRAM CALLED
RESILIENT FLORIDA THAT WE PUT A
BILLION DOLLARS INTO OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS, AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES ARE ABLE TO GET
MONEY THAT'S MATCHED BY THE
STATE TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS AND HARDEN SOME OF
THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE.
IF YOU LOOK AT SOUTHWEST
FLORIDA, I THINK IT'S PROBABLY
GOING TO BE SHOWN THAT SOME OF
WHAT THEY DID HAS WORKED BECAUSE
I THINK THAT THE DAMAGE COULD
HAVE BEEN MUCH MORE EXTENSIVE IN
SOME OF THEIR UNDERLYING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
I THINK WE'RE THE ONLY STATE
THAT'S EVER DONE THAT AND THAT'S
MADE A BIG DIFFERENCE.
IT'S MADE A BIG DIFFERENCE AND
THAT'S AVAILABLE.
IT'S A 2-YEAR-OLD PROGRAM.
BUT THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY TO BE
PUTTING IN THE SYSTEM.
>> Reporter: GOVERNOR, WE EXPECT
TO SEE THE DEATH TOLL RISE NOW
AND THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO CAN'T GET IN TOUCH WITH
THEIR LOVED ONES.
WHAT'S YOUR MESSAGE TO PEOPLE AS
WE SEE THAT NUMBER GO UP AND UP
EACH DAY?
>> WELL, LOOK, I THINK, YOU
KNOW, THIS IS BASICALLY A
CATEGORY FIVE STORM THAT ALSO
HAD FLOODING LIKE WE'VE NEVER
SEEN.
IF YOU THINK OF HURRICANE
MICHAEL, IT WAS LIKE A TORNADO
THAT WENT THROUGH NORTHWEST
FLORIDA, VERY DAMAGING.
BUT YOU WERE IN PANAMA CITY, YOU
COULD POTENTIALLY HAVE LOST
EVERYTHING.
IF YOU WERE IN PANAMA CITY
BEACH, YOU PRETTY MUCH HAD
NOTHING BECAUSE IT WAS
RELATIVELY FOCUSED.
THIS STORM, YOU HAD THAT IN
PLACES LIKE FORT MYERS BEACH,
BUT YOU ALSO HAD THIS MASSIVE
EVENT THAT'S CAUSED FLOODING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND SO IT'S JUST A MASSIVE
IMPACT AND, YOU KNOW,
UNFORTUNATELY YOU HAVE -- YOU
HAVE DISRUPTION OF HOMES, YOU
HAVE FATALITIES AND IT'S A
DIFFICULT THING TO DEAL WITH FOR
SURE.
>> Reporter: YOUR MESSAGE TO
PEOPLE WHO CAN'T GET IN CONTACT
WITH THEIR LOVED ONES?
>> WHAT WE'VE DONE, WE'RE
BRINGING HERE -- WE BROUGHT THEM
TO SOUTHWEST FLORIDA AND OTHER
PARTS, WE'RE BRINGING THE ELON
MUSK SATELLITE RECEIVERS AND SO
PEOPLE WILL BE ABLE TO GET
ONLINE AT THESE PODS TO BE ABLE
TO LET PEOPLE KNOW THAT THEY'RE
OKAY.
OBVIOUSLY, YOU KNOW, WE -- THE
TELECOM COMPANIES ARE DOING WHAT
THEY CAN.
I KNOW THEY BRING IN TOWERS AND
STUFF LIKE THAT.
SOME OF THEM SUFFERED EXTENSIVE
DAMAGES.
BUT I THINK ON THE INTERNET, TO
BE ABLE TO COME HERE, GET WHAT
YOU NEED, YOU WILL BE ABLE TO IF
WE BRING TO THE PODS, YOU WILL
BE ABLE TO LOG ON.
THAT WILL BE COMFORT FOR A LOT
OF PEOPLE.
>> HOW WOULD YOU DESCRIBE YOUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION?
>> Reporter: WHAT CAN WE DO
TOGETHER TO GET THIS THING
MOVING FORWARD?
>> I DON'T THINK YOU'VE EVER
SEEN A STATE SPRING INTO ACTION
LIKE WE'VE SEEN HERE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THESE PODS,
USUALLY THE PODS ARE NOT SET UP
UNTIL 96 HOURS AFTER THE STORM
LEAVES.
WE HAD PODS SET UP SAD WHEN THE
STORM LEFT ON THURSDAY NIGHT.
WE HAD A LOT OF STUFF PRESTAGE
AND THEN YOU HAD ALL OF THESE
PRIVATE GROUPS COMING IN TO
HELP.
YOU HAVE ALL OF THESE OTHER
AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
COMING IN TO HELP.
A LOT OF THESE AGENCIES, LIKE
SOUTHWEST FLORIDA, THEY WERE ALL
PREPARING TO GO HELP TAMPA IN
ST. PETE A WEEK AGO WHEN THIS
STUFF -- ON MONDAY THEY WERE
MAKING PREPARATIONS TO ACTUALLY
DO THAT.
THINGS CHANGE.
AND NOW YOU HAVE PEOPLE FROM
TAMPA, THE PANHANDLE COMING DOWN
TO THIS PART OF FLORIDA.
AND SO I THINK PEOPLE HAVE
REALLY PULLED TOGETHER.
I THINK THAT THEY'VE DONE A
REALLY GOOD JOB.
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK AHEAD,
OBVIOUSLY, BUT I THINK THE
RESILIENCE HAS BEEN GREAT.
FRIDAY MORNING IN CAPE CORAL,
WHICH IS VERY CLOSE TO GROUND
ZERO WHERE THE HURRICANE HIT,
YOU HAD PUBLIX OPEN, THINGS ARE
SPRINGING BACK.
I DOUBT YOU WOULD HAVE SEEN THAT
IN SOME OF THESE OTHER MAJOR
STORMS THAT WE'VE SEEN OVER THE
PAST 20, 30 YEARS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
AND SO I THINK THE SPIRIT IS
GREAT AND I DO THINK PEOPLE
PULLED TOGETHER WELL.
WE'RE GOING TO HEAD BACK OVER TO
THE --
>> AND THAT WAS MY COLLEAGUE
SPEAKING WITH GOVERNOR RON
DeSANTIS THERE ASKING QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE RESPONSE TO HURRICANE
IAN.
I DON'T KNOW IF NADIA IS STILL
WITH ME.
NADIA, IF YOU'RE THERE, I JUST
WANT TO ASK YOU --
>> Reporter:
>> -- WHAT WERE YOUR THOUGHTS
FROM THE GOVERNOR.
IT SOUNDS LIKE HE'S VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE DECISION THAT
IS WERE MADE IN TERMS OF WHEN
THESE EVACUATION ORDERS WERE
ISSUED, THAT RESIDENTS ARE
ASKING A LOT OF QUESTIONS ABOUT.
>> Reporter: YEAH, HE SEEMED
FRUSTRATED WHEN I STARTED ASKING
HIM QUESTIONS ABOUT LEE COUNTY
AND THEIR MANDATORY EVACUATION.
YOU CAN SEE THE GOVERNOR NOW --
I WANT YOU TO TAKE A LOOK AS HE
LOADS UP ON A BOAT HERE AND
HEADS TO THE OTHER SIDE OF
HIGHWAY 70.
THAT'S WHERE HE'S GOING TO HAVE
ANOTHER PRESS CONFERENCE.
HE REALLY CAME ON THIS SIDE TO
SHAKE THE HANDS OF SOME NATIONAL
GUARDS MEMBERS AND SOME PEOPLE
HERE WHO HAVE BEEN STRANDED
BECAUSE OF THE FLOODWATERS.
BUT WHEN I ASKED HIM ABOUT LEE
COUNTY NOT HAVING THAT MANDATORY
EVACUATION UNTIL THE DAY BEFORE
THE STORM, HE FIRED BACK AND
SAID, WHERE DID YOU THINK THE
STORM WAS GOING TO LAND?
AND THAT CONE, THE EYE OF THE
STORM WAS NOT SET TOWARDS FORT
MYERS AND LEE COUNTY UNTIL LATER
ON.
AND SO HE DOUBLED DOWN, AGAIN,
SAYING THAT HE STANDS BY WHAT
HAPPENED IN LEE COUNTY AND
SAYING THAT HINDSIGHT IS 20/20
AND WE CAN LOOK AT IT NOW AND
SAY WHAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN DONE.
BUT HE SAYS HE BELIEVES THEY DID
WHAT THEY THOUGHT WAS BEST,
BASED ON THE TRACK OF THE STORM.
NOW WE KNOW FROM REVIEWING THE
DOCUMENTS THAT LEE COUNTY'S OWN
RECORDS SHOW THAT THEY SHOULD
HAVE THAT MANDATORY EVACUATION
ORDER.
THEY COULD HAVE HAD THAT AS SOON
AS SUNDAY.
SO WHEN I ASKED THE GOVERNOR
ABOUT THAT, HE DOUBLED DOWN AND
SAID THEY DID THE BEST THEY
COULD AND THAT HE FELT LIKE
THEIR EVACUATION ORDER WAS PUT
IN A TIMELY MANNER.
THAT IS NOT WHAT WE'RE HEARING
FROM OTHERS WHO ARE CRITICIZING
LEE COUNTY.
I FOLLOWED UP AND ASKED HIM,
WELL, THE SURROUNDING COUNTIES
AROUND LEE COUNTY DID HAVE
MANDATORY EVACUATION ORDERS
BEFORE TUESDAY.
AND